what to use the
most
interesting beautiful moments in the
history of science what stands out right
and then we can pull at that thread
all right
well i like to think of
events that have
a major impact and involve both
beautiful
conceptual
mathematical
if we're talking physical structures
work and are associated as well with
probing
experimental
situations
so um among my favorites is one of the
most famous
which was the young isaac newtons
work with the colors produced when you
pass sunlight through a prism
and why do i like that
um it's not profoundly mathematical in
one sense
doesn't need it initially it needs the
following though which begins to show
you i think a little bit about what gets
involved when you've got a smart
individual who's trying to monkey around
with stuff and finds new things about it
first let me say that the the notion the
prevailing notion going back to
antiquity was that um
colors are produced in a sense by
modifying or tinting
white light that they're modifications
of white light in other words the colors
are not in the sunlight in any way
okay
now
what newton did following experiments
done by descartes before him who came to
very different conclusions
he took a prism
you might ask where do you get prisms in
the you know 1660s
county fairs they were very popular they
were pretty crude with bubbles in them
and everything but they produced colors
so you could buy them at county fairs
and things very popular oh so they were
modifying the white light
well to create colors they were
creating colors from it well known
and what he did was the following he was
by this time even though he's very young
a very good mathematician
and he could use the
then known laws for how light behaves
when it goes through glass
to calculate what should happen
if you took light from the sun passed it
from a hole through a little hole
then hit the prism
goes out of the prism goes strikes a
wall a long distance away and makes a
splash of light never mind the colors
for a moment makes a splash of light
there he was very smart
first of all
he abstracts from the colors themselves
even though that's what everybody's
paying attention to
initially and because what he knows is
this he knows that if you take this
prism
and you turn it to a certain particular
angle that he knew
what it should be because he could
calculate things and
very few other people in europe at the
time could calculate things like he
could
that if you turn the prism to that
particular angle
then the sun which is of course a circle
when its light passes through this
little hole and then into the prism on
the far distant wall
should still make a circle
but it doesn't
it makes a very long image okay
and this
led him to a very different conception
of light indicating that there are
different types of light in the sunlight
now
to go beyond that what's particularly
interesting i think is the following
when he published uh this paper which
got him into a controversy
he really didn't describe it all what he
did he just gave you some numbers
now i just told you that you had to set
this prism at a certain angle
right
you would think because we do have his
notes and so on
you would think that he took some kind
of complicated measuring device to set
the prism he didn't
he held it in his hand
that's all
and he twiddled it around
and what was he doing it turns out
that when you twiddle the prism around
at the point where you should get a
circle from a circle
it also is the place where the image
does not move very fast so if you want
to get close to there you just twiddle
it this is manipulative experimentation
taking advantage through his
mathematical knowledge
of the inherent inaccuracies that label
let you come to exact conclusions
regardless of the built-in problematics
of measurement he's the only one i know
of doing anything like that at the time
yeah
well even still there's very few people
that are able to have to calculate as
well as he did to be a theoretician
and an experimentalist
like in the same moment
right um
it's true although until
uh the um
really the well into the 20th century
maybe the beginning of the 20th century
really
most of the most significant
experimental results
produced in the 1800s
which laid the foundations for light
electricity electrodynamics and so on
um even
hydrodynamics and whatnot were also
produced by people who are both
excellent
calculators
very talented mathematicians and good
with their hands experimentally
you